premier ministre madame la ministre de
la santé je voulais vous interroger sur
trois points le premier set comment se
fait-il que dans ce pays on ne s'occupe
pas un petit peu plus quand on voit le
budget de la sécurité sociale dans
l'état où il est depuis des années un
peu plus des problèmes de prévention des
produits de prévention des produits de
sécurité alimentaire des produits de
diététique et des produits de régime
comme cela se fait dans la plupart des
pays d'europe particulièrement les
périples les pays d'europe du nord et
l'allemagne c'est ma première question
la deuxième question c'est ce que disait
le professeur greffe
voici une trentaine d'années comment se
fait-il que dans les études pour les
médecins il y ait cinq fois moins
d'études sur la nutrition que pour les
vétérinaires qui connaissent beaucoup
mieux la nutrition et c'est eux qui la
contrôle du reste enfin la troisième
question
la troisième question c'est tout
simplement comment se fait-il que la
dgccrf et la rsm ne se préoccupe pas des
produits qui rentrent sur le marché en
provenance de suisse du luxembourg de
belgique notamment absolument pas
conforme à la réglementation avec des
informations médicales
alors qu'ils n'ont aucune qualité pour
l'être donc sur ces trois questions
j'aimerais votre réponse merci pour vous